every modern website needs seven  features one legally you need the user  to accept cookies to exploit their  privacy for advertisers provide multiple  options to make this as confusing as  possible two use the geolocation API to  request their location so we know  exactly where they live and where  they're going three get permission for  push notifications because who doesn't  love getting unsolicited notifications  from some random website for launch an  obnoxiously animated modal window to  harvest their email for the newsletter  5. auto play a video but make sure to  disable the controls so it can only be  stopped by a skilled JavaScript  programmer 6. this user might be a bot  so let's verify them with an impossible  captcha 7. at this point the user might  try to leave to prevent this and still  get a conversion disable the back button  launch a pop-up that says the user has  violated the government and provide a  link to your Bitcoin address to resolve  for a nominal fee